Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright!
An original idea is not always a good idea!
In this age of remakes and reboots, originality
can be extremely valuable.
However, just because an idea is original
does not mean it is good.
Dr. Bright is correct that no one has ever
tried to test cosmetics on SCP-682 before
but that does not mean that putting lipstick
and mascara on the hard-to-destroy reptile
is a good plan.
All Foundation personnel are now required
to attend a seminar on the difference between
an original idea and a good idea before being
allowed to interact with Dr. Bright.
Don't let him be a bad influence on you!